well it is official the summer movie
season is now over cinematic seasons
we're into fall now so let's review a
fall movie mild 22 so mild 22 - you
might have seen ads for recently it's
directed by Peter Berg which Peter Berg
I'm like I'm still 50/50 on him coming
up in a couple years ago he had a
stretch we're back to back he made two
movies I really loved but still for the
most part his averages you can flip a
coin to find out which version of Peter
Berg you're gonna get sometimes the coin
comes up hey you're Peter Berg you're
talented other times you're $0.99
Michael Bay we'll see which one we got
from my old 22 so mild 22 is essentially
an escort mission Mark Wahlberg and his
crew have to transport this person who
has information and his information will
stop a terrorist attack or a series of
terrorist attacks so they have to escort
this person from point A onto a plane to
point B I'm assuming 22 miles they
probably said it in the movie but it was
upon reflection of the title where I
just realized it was probably 22 miles
and now waves of guys are trying to kill
this person so they've got to protect
him while they're driving him down the
road and this movie had moments of fun
in it probably because of the premise
the premise is such a simple premise
it's hard to screw it up and not make it
entertaining which I feel like a lot of
movies do though it's an escort mission
bring on the violence bring on the gun
fire bring on protecting the dude at the
very least we'll get some pretty solid
kills in this movie and there are some
pretty solid kills in this movie when
this movie wants to be exciting it's
pretty exciting I could go without the
shakey cam [ __ ] during the action
sequences though it really feels like in
a lot of action sequences it was like
alright punch
cut all right we're gonna reposition go
down to where you ended the punch great
now you got to do another move alright
arm lock alright cut right now we're
gonna move the camera behind him and
then you're gonna finish the next move
which is another punch punch alright cut
so every action sequence looks very
choppy blurring Cohen's in this movie or
is it KO Han usually Cohen has an e I'm
gonna call her lauren cohan and if I'm
wrong well I don't make fun of your
accent don't make fun of mine I can't
have an accent it's what it is is it
tomato or tomato but I was glad to see
her in something other than the walking
dead you got to show another side of her
in this movie or at least a more
hardcore side of Maggie without the
southern accent just set up at this
movie was so great I was instantly on
board with her Mark Wahlberg their team
and their goals and then things just
start going downhill cuz Mark Wahlberg's
character is just a dick in this movie
he's not
a likeable day you were gonna be an
arrogant douchebag you have to justify
it in your work in your actions house is
a douchebag but he straight-up saves
lives and solves the puzzle Sherlock
Holmes is pretty much housed the same
thing Sherlock Holmes was first house
was based off of him so house is like
Sherlock Holmes I reversed it is it
tomato or tomato though but I feel like
with arrogant dick is more than just
soldier you have to be intellectually
higher than everybody and although
there's a beginning montage in this
movie illustrating how gifted Mark
Wahlberg's character is he's
intellectually on another level from the
other kids that's the only real
reference to it it's not like he solves
puzzles not like it ever comes into
effect in the movie the only thing you
see in reference to it that he has his
rubber band on his wrist that he snaps
and it's [ __ ] annoying I don't need
him to have a thing just make him a good
soldier and if he's a good soldier great
that doesn't mean he's intellectually on
some other level from other people you
can be a good soldier and not be
intellectually gifted you can be
intellectually gifted and not be a good
soldier
there's nothing he does to illustrate
why they even put that in the beginning
of the movie other than to have a rubber
band that he snaps on his wrist out of
noise use it's not just him it's like
everyone needs a thing like one of the
guys in this movie does that that drunk
test with his hands that cops will do to
people when they pull them over you
can't just have the characters be the
characters they need a gimmick they need
a thing that got a really bagging on
this movie there really had moments of
fun in it it also had annoyance in it I
guess that's the most frustrating thing
about this movie this movie had just
leaned into the fact that it's a cliche
premise but we're gonna make it exciting
there's gonna be groundbreaking know
where the character is gonna be
groundbreaking no we're gonna get it
done and we might just make a perfectly
enjoyable movie in the process dammit
but now they had to overreach with their
characters and make them dude snappy
weird things characters were unlikable
some of the editing choices just
confused me and in the end they
overreach and it compromised what should
have been an easy success I'm saying is
I'm not gonna remember this movie in
t-minus one day yep already forgot write
some mild 22 you haven't seen it you
even know about this movie what's your
favorite escort mission movie whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you seen here and you wanna see
more click right here to see more
[Music]